Microsoft in the news again and the ever  going the ever born Saga  that is the Activision Blizzard cake man  so it appears that Microsoft says it  offered Sony a 10-year deal to keep Call  of Duty on PlayStation video game  chronicle.com Xbox told the New York  Times that it offered a 10-year deal to  Sony on November 11th so he has since  declined to comment on this claim  Microsoft has now accused Sony of  misleading Regulators stating that Sony  has overstated the importance of Call of  Duty to its viability PlayStation boss  Jim Ryan has since responded stating  that it's not true that Saudi has misled  Regulators Microsoft is a tech giant  with a long history of dominating  Industries and it is highly likely that  the choices Gamers have today will  disappear if the deal goes ahead